[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so so I told them pub GI Council I'd
rather play on my phone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I wonder what we're gonna see in this
hitman 2 demo today I'm just so excited
to see hitman two I'm gonna kill so many
people so so I told them pub G on
console I'd rather play on my phone hi
Jen what are you guys doing here it is
GameSpot IGN fancy seeing you here did
you guys figure out what your name
stands for yet huh at least you don't
get confused at Gamestop you guys are
like the blue shell of pizzas already no
put the gaming puns they'll cut straight
to the point you're overstepping the our
territory what are you even doing here
this supposed to be our exclusive demo
got this mysterious invitation in the
mail
I think we're here to play some hitman
two ladies and gentlemen of GameSpot and
IGN
you're both formidable teams but which
of you are worthy of the title the
ultimate hit man in Colombia there are
three targets and it's your team's job
to pull off the perfect hit however if
you wanted to do this the old-fashioned
way we will just hired
agent 47 instead you're going to
assassinate them to the most unique way
you can your team must grab the plan to
deal with each target the more credits
are killed the better then you can
compete live against one another on gone
state to see who can execute their plan
the most efficiently your planning rules
await beyond these doors who would be
the ultimate hitman of gaming will soon
find out now go
our initial first note we're gonna go in
this cave system that's gonna be a
really good way to get to the target
okay the idea okay so the targets are in
a mansion a village and a field
laboratory wait so they get guns and we
get rubber ducks
kill that shaman take his costume and
then not even use it so proud of you man
somebody makes a concrete way to get a
ton of point
this is great but we're just butch boy
the whole time we'll never find them
maybe instead of murdering Jorge we
should probably try to find him a
chiropractor
I guess that also works
talk about a nice situation
[Music]
that's coffee yeah good
good talk ya see out there alright guys
I feel really good about our plans we
did it it's perfect
watch GameSpot a place to be feeling
good man what we would say
[Music]
I can't wait to bring you all down with
the whole world watch please meeting you
guys will be easier than getting a
platinum trophy and spider-man are you
guys kidding me beating you guys is
gonna be easier than getting a chicken
dinner
hey I love you guys in Kingdom Hearts 2
who did you play again the nobodies the
only party you guys were invited to this
year was Mario's somebody called Delilah
from Firewatch because that was a bird
maybe but at least we're not the luigi's
of games media guys wait and settle this
on launch day we got who the real hitmen
are fine launch day it is see that
be sure to tune in on November 13th to
see what happens next
Greg Miller will host our showdown live
as we pull off our plans as well as
compete in the all-new ghost mode
IGN versus GameSpot it's on what's up
everybody welcome to the IG inverse game
spot mano a mano hit man to challenge
brought to you by hitman - it must have
been a stretch to get that sponsorship
I'm your host Greg Miller from kind of
funny and for the next two hours we will
pit IGN and GameSpot together and just
what can only be described as the battle
for the ages guys ladies and gentlemen
everyone knows I Gian GameSpot lots of
bad blood here it's been this way
forever it's terrible
finally one video game where you get to
kill indiscriminately we're gonna bring
it together decide which side is the
most blood thirsty or is everybody ready
okay okay the way it works ladies and
gentlemen is simple I am Greg Miller
from kind of funny I used to work at IGN
GameSpot hires me for a lot of stuff so
does IGN now so I'm the most impartial
person here because of course there's
only one great video game website these
days and it's giant bombs in that you
might say well then drag your the tank
obviously for GameSpot no of course
CBS kind of ruined on Tom when they took
him but you know no I'm kidding around
I'm kidding around I will be completely
impartial today and even though the game
does have scoring mechanisms isn't we
will be ignoring all of them I will be
taking copious notes and giving out
points willy-nilly as I see fit
much like Dumbledore team I Jim let's
get you guys introduced Duggan what's up
Mitch what's up Stephen what's up how
are you guys fantastic you all said
what's up yes very was that plan and
then when we when we out sure will say
keep it locked
you know they up to the the brainwashing
when you start you know those embedded
in your brain well it's just if you have
the intro and you have the outro nobody
cares what happens in there are exactly
Duggan how confident are you guys in
winny him an extremely confident I think
we have a fantastic lineup I think
myself I'm somewhat seasoned but but
Mitchell's been playing hitman since the
series inception and Steve
is our shooter battle royale experts
only played 40 minutes of hitman - he's
just I think it's more like 40 seconds
40 seconds okay he's too busy getting
chicken dinners in victory right Steven
are those skills of getting chicken
dinners and driving your cars around and
shooting people in the head gonna carry
over to the stealth again I've heard you
can't build in this game that is a
hundred there is no no Mitchell is your
apparent expertise in hitman going to
balance out Stevens naivete I think so I
think Steven doesn't give himself enough
credit he's so good at those games and
he's good at so I think I think that
we'll balance it out okay and plus he's
got me and Doug and Ted just be the the
Oracle is here ladies oh that's a point
for reference right there they currently
lead one to zero but let's check in with
GameSpot yes
I'm feeling great about 20 hours of
practice I think I'm ready to go Lucy
Ben how are you very well good yeah we
did practice run this morning I'm
feeling good about it confident happened
really quickly I think in like 30
minutes so when I try to pace ourselves
well again remember this is the this is
the wild card yeah me is that I don't
care about what the game does the score
I'm looking for creativity I'm looking
for you to screw up I'm looking for you
to bounce back I'm looking for you to
mention patreon.com slash kind of funny
games what if we wrote that in corpses I
don't want to say automatic win but
that's been how confident are your
skills here at hitman - pretty confident
actually yeah he's pretty seasoned I've
been playing a lot of a lot of hit man's
really got into it in blood money and
really into this one yeah I'm feeling it
okay great yeah do you
chastity Ben feel like you have in
per hand here on IG and sees how you
used to work here at IgM like myself I
mean didn't want to go right for it and
say yes but yeah yeah yeah that's it you
know how they think
right exactly we know exactly heads guys
gentlemen here is how it's going to work
today we are gonna do two rounds of
hitman two the first one pretty standard
an assassination challenge what it will
be is the Columbia level there are three
targets to kill in there and it is a
relay challenge meaning that everybody
will go over there they'll start playing
not everybody team by team
IGN won the coin toss they go over first
they go over there one by one every kill
they have to relay out bring somebody
back into the next one so whoever you
get the first then you get your three
kills I go through and I do this I say
what I like that's how we go that way we
give you some points based on what's
happening by Jean like I said he's gonna
start you guys won the coin flip yes
have you run this level a lot once or
twice once or twice okay my dad I mean
hundreds whoa you're beat yeah I see
what you're doing you're playing it down
playing it yes yes okay well I'm just
trying to get in the opponent's head
just a little bit yeah cuz that's you
know agent 47 wouldn't do that you just
wouldn't see him but I'm not agent 47
yes exactly
Mitchell actually has a bar code tattoo
he just can't see it round two is there
gonna be another challenge another relay
challenge this one we go smoke but we'll
get to that later
for now let's start round one team IgM
who's starting everything it's gonna be
me
Oh round of applause every team idea
Mitchell this is hitman two
mano a mano challenge guys universe
GameSpot's brought to you by hitman -
who would have thunk they'd sponsors see
it's funny cuz the games
[Music]
- one point I already say no all right
three kills
yeah let's do let's get some contacts
I'm gonna give him a - point I'm gonna
watch the intro hi James back to zero
here you'd see it loading up and
apparently we're going after two young
versions of Stanley rest in peace
handsome lady here we go now Lucy does
the fact that Mitchell's been playing
this game forever
every man ever getting your head what's
your hit man knows I didn't really play
that much I was kind of as Maya the
series in a bar but I've been bad at it
yeah but with this ones I was playing a
bunch last week I was playing some of
the weekend and I'm like yeah I've got
some strats I've got I've got Marut I
feel confident did you go back and watch
giant bombs hit this because again giant
bomb does a lot of great cover
dress for the job you want that's what I
he doesn't altruism with the point
distribution you know a brown-nosing
sense probably - no no no that was on it
like you see it flying purity again you
can't trust gigs here we go
agent 47 starting in just a lovely
blouse and pant combo Mitchell showed us
the deep V V yes turn around
see this is the problem you say he's
trying to blend in but he's gonna stay
in that oh yeah
everything dreamy telling me about this
lovely gentleman go okay get a wrench
immediately uh so so Greg yeah how do
you how do you feel about shamans uh
ever since like Papa Shango in the WWF
yeah the mystical world that scares me
you know again well what how do you feel
about them Oh what you know how I feel
doesn't really matter because depend on
sure well I want you I mean I think it's
time you messed them up personally don't
you yeah right
I don't want to get I gotta be impartial
over here listen to what's going on over
here for a second okay again don't there
this is not a timed round not race so
you know you take your time you put on
the most impressive kills the funniest
kills zero kills it doesn't matter to me
you know I mean you just
if you want to limp this thing if you
want to linger this all the way through
though two or three o'clock when this
stream ends sure I mean you win by
default
probably kind of I think 47 other team
never play because they're literally
blind so whatever I do did this guy and
unders of practice attempts if you're in
your practice things did don't let her
get a well win oh my god sorry you may
think this looks bad listen you know
what I think it looks like I think it
looks like five points for team he's put
on his showings you don't mean again if
he's like professional wrestling what is
it what does she mean in terms of doing
you the Harry Potter houses we slippery
oh no no not gonna move fair enough
no no it's not that I mean they're the
slither is the evil right yeah
who's the evil this is a loaded thing we
should have put in the front this is all
in good humor I love Giant Bomb who's
evil eye.i fine oh yeah well there you
go then easy allies they don't think
they're evil but let me tell you brandy
was kind of funny is Gryffindor I agree
No gets a bad rap but they're somebody's
do you think man you know how many times
have you played this mission but you
still didn't know those people wouldn't
be behind jazz on the keyboard [ __ ] in
the Moody I understand it gets there all
right we're good okay all bodies are
ladies gentleman heed to point out to
you as well and throughout this I will
be checking my phone and many other
people will be as well it's not because
we're ignoring you or don't like you
we're looking at the chat to see what
hateful hateful things some people are
saying so we can ban those people now my
question is you send out Mitchell our
newly team on genes best pal yes
are you batting last or second okay okay
your your clean up you're donating a
dead last
yeah okay I mean I think hitman is one
of those games that things go from bad
to where it's kind of exponentially so
if you mess up Shirley Sherrod Mitchell
arguably did but he's recovered he
killed them all kill one person
accidentally snapping that okay well
that happened sometimes ask me a little
bit of research happening here what
could be in that red container you know
I didn't even know you could go down
that way Mitchell I was always going yet
back through the gate here we are
so hitman is one of those games that you
play through kind of get to this sense
as you're going on the fly as to what
opportunities present themselves but
once you know that stuff you can just
kind of go back and just hit the big
bullet points and what he's doing right
now is getting a CPU for the machine
cocaine and he's been spotted come on
Mitchell
you've been playing forever you said
right in the head didn't wanna do that
his buddy doesn't even know what's up
not kill not kill still fine yeah you've
left 10 witnesses but they're
unconscious with witnesses which is the
important yeah they're gonna wake up be
like I saw something and then fell
asleep you know what back to my normal
Patrol nothing nothing out of the
ordinary video games no no red flags on
yellow flags all good everything is fine
downplaying the mistakes I like we have
to remain critical of our own team or
else we can't improve I've never sent
hygiene always been respected chastity
what are you thinking as you see your
opponent
Mitchell play here I think what I know
what kilise going for but I'm not gonna
say anything just in case he changes his
mind but he's doing pretty good now I've
got that mascar I don't know how I feel
about that shaman maskers but you know
do you do you you say no one really you
know it's like my favorite thing is when
you said guys this is very important
they're all blind they won't be able to
see me I also hate to point out that he
accomplished literally nothing he Drabek
rhobar yeah taking out a camera again
those points don't matter
thankfully those points don't matter
maybe a points based on it maybe I won't
nobody knows just keeping true to the
the can you are true to your promise
I guess I'd hmm mitch is gonna think it
through here you know
I assume here trying to lure a man or a
lure one of your targets over I'm trying
to lure the worker inside this Hut
so that can steals clothes gotcha I've
seen it once I've seen it again his
pants exactly exactly that's that's what
that means
have you ever hear that anywhere else
that's what that means Ignacio London
the chat says go IGN completely
unrecognized totally looks exactly of
course there's no hair we've got it you
got a blend in we're gonna we're gonna
make Jorge happy first
why is one of our workers constantly
crouching so what's going on right now
is that this machine makes Jorge's
cocaine and he's really upset because it
broke for whatever reason he was
expecting us apart sure part fell was in
that red box that I got and I just
installed it so now that she's working
and he's really happy about it
Tenzin follows up and says go games stop
I'd like to think that was completely
intentional so thank you
well yeah a ton of Corbeau and our chats
and GameSpot is the best so thank you I
can't verify that I verify that I'm
gonna give you back a point bring you
back to zero
thanks games stuff Mitchell what are you
doing there
yeah what is what's happening what's
happening what's happening is about is
that Jorge it's about to become what he
loves so much
okay it's about to become cocaine Wow
[Laughter]
who knew humans were made of cocaine now
you need a relay out sir all right Doug
back me yeah you got to be tagged yeah
we because much right now because of
course it's when this is more fun and
always lighter stuff it'll come down to
the tag there's the crazy GoPro cam
Merida will flex feel oh my god
I'll tell you what idea that's another
point right there
you keep that coming gotta get this ps4
controller out of the way first things
first
and we are now subtracting five points
they're back they're back some soup line
I know wait did you already pick up the
cooking brick you did okay great
you know I knew that was coming but
that's okay it's calculated the key to
the manor yeah I'm all about speed is
that worry that's where you're gonna
excel here that's where I'm gonna I'm
gonna show off so much my speed oh well
I know but I got Billy still be jogging
to let her get your head alright maybe
my strategy was flawed so this guy loves
radio radio interests he died oh there
was styrofoam peanuts in there that's
very thoughtful nice and safe an a
circle all rights in the IG and chat
what am i watching you are watching i
gen verse GameSpot in the hitman to mono
e mono challenge that's right
for another hour and a half we are
playing hitman two it's brought to you
by hitman Express bro yeah hitman two
brought to you I hit man have you heard
about hitman two
ah they're playing to decide what is the
best website what is Paris is it what's
better who've already lost literary
rounds and here we are
the games media showdown everybody
wanted that they thought would never
happen and here we are
oh this is perfect this is what you want
yeah we have we have a hippo Whisperer
here okay who has the gift of communing
with hippopotamus gotcha hippopotamus I
hippopotamus azusa's what you gonna do
here it's like a Paragon renegade
decision look I know the importance of
getting your protein and this hippo oh
what's he doing what's gonna happen
there is he coming up all right well
that's a little preview our hippopotamus
is ready and of course this is the pet
of Rico Delgado but he's been kind of a
little bit reluctant so it's a very
large appetizer
he's been reluctant he's been hiding but
we gave him some protein and now the
hippo is thirsty for blood but at this
point I'm gonna pull a fast one mm-hmm
and I am so good at hitman that I'm
gonna play a second game get off my
machine get off hey you know what I
thought that is my machine login to my
account
what are you doing oh my gosh Duggan
we're still gonna we're still gonna make
that first kill count it's all gonna be
good but well I think I got plenty of
time
see the idea is to beat this mission
before that little scripted thing I did
in the other game it resolves itself I
am I am blown away ladies Joan this is
not working
it's run by machines cy you
I mean if Mozart walked in and he saw
your piano I'd say well should I go play
I also say how are you alive Mozart one
day the zombies are here all right
almost done some Franco all the
bodyguards as well as the targets one of
these targets is getting a little bit
wary but I mean what a show you know
what I mean
oh we got a couple left we got one in
the helicopter it's not over yet I could
still mess up but I want I can't wait to
see why it's because I was still the
joke I'm still doing the joke when I
stop going to jail and I was like oh man
I can't wait to see my friends Brian
altano in Mexico like none of them
people are gonna be on the stream and I
was like oh one more a team like I've
never seen before
oh my gosh mud wolf I'm getting
achievements on your account all right
how's things going over here you
probably do it again if you want to
should I do it again Duggan you get five
points for team IgM if you're counting
at home right now it's seven to zero
hi Jim I'm gonna go I'm gonna go on a
little bit of an exploration mission
because basically what's happening is
that hippo trainer has had the
realization that he's been successful in
luring this hippopotamus out of hiding
so he's gone to find his employer and
and to show him that his pet is happy
and well-fed once again but we still
have more time in spite of me
showboating so we're just gonna go in a
little cyborg man says shudders - James
Duggan's the biceps oh thanks - agree
thing a beauty well you gotta do here
James you got make it a little bit
easier for for Stephen to get back to
the yeah yeah instruction yard do you
think I should do oh I think I should
not go that'd be great
Oh what change the key so bad that's not
what I want
no sloppy that was disgustingly sloppy
we're minus e 1.4 that you know what the
problem was Stephen got in here and
changed all these to fortnight keybinds
we're gonna keep waiting things are cool
you know what I should probably do the
freshness guys here or is this still now
this guy's still happening okay now I
show but it a little bit there but man
it all went so wrong so I'm just gonna
relax chill out just hang out kids just
put on a good show exactly what a
specimen of a human being he's got here
oh you didn't kill them so they got back
up don't inform your boss that I'm down
here no I gotta go to rampage folks I'm
sorry
Schaller rampage active this is what I
mean this is what the people who don't
want it to see let's be real no no no
the hippo is still hungry it's okay
disappearing if no idea where I'm at my
pride I felt it torn asunder I'm sorry
if you just where do i what do I even do
now well you lost another point you've
lost the point I feel like I feel like I
have to be the best thing over again
what's that autosave that was okay well
no this is the save man it was the
classic you know how Laurie of The
Tortoise and the hare right here and
another computer walk crazy I might do
it again I think I saw huh yes yes there
was no autosave so we either start the
mission all over or we do this is your
first mark dead yeah we're a we're a
Franco's dead okay check it out it's all
good folks relax you know I appreciate
how much GameSpot was all over you call
you on shenanigans they advanced they're
keeping it real yeah thank goodness
[Laughter]
at the end of this he's using different
save so the time spent yeah this is an
entire different situation at the time
okay
[Laughter]
these casket matches if you've ever
loved it
all right let's try this again keep your
track that's probably the fourth
pro-wrestling reference so far and let
me you can take bet to the chat is it
gonna be the last it will not be the
last see how that chats doing all right
well now I feel as though I've shamed
myself to a point where I need to beat
the sniper challenge twice in the time
that I'm waiting so there otherwise
we're just gonna be sitting around
waiting for Rico to look at her to drag
his butt over here but I think your best
use of that time you know there's no
time limit and also don't worry about
the time because steam is just gonna
make it up oh yeah he's a bro he's a bro
so this is something new basically
there's this mm-hmm ring if you're
hidden in the bush obviously if you
haven't been seen people cannot see you
outside of it so someone could be right
next to you and this is used a lot and a
really cool thing is you can do it in
crowds if you might really yeah so wait
so like right there the ring indicates
that if they're outside of the ring they
can't see you but if they walk inside
the ring they'd see you yes is that the
idea yeah yeah and we're gonna speed
this up a little bit I'm gonna toss that
coin distract that guard so I don't need
to satiate the hippopotamus for the
guard I can just use this why he's mine
it's off by the place hey are you
looking at these notes don't look at
these notes hey don't worry about me guy
look the hippos back Hey look at that
well your friends here you did your job
you're not gonna get executed you should
be over there cool all right okay no
wait right here I'll go find your master
I went in the chaton games fun said that
run was so sloppy right y'all right guy
you know you want to check out that
hippo
I mean you shouldn't but I feel like the
hippos eating enough something anyone
can we Wikipedia that there's no the
Chat Chat please tell us Alexa do hippos
laugh ok Google's oh okay the cameraman
leaned over and asked me to show the
score I thought he was gonna tell me if
hippos can laugh right now the score is
ijen five points GameSpot won okay we're
gonna repeat history here I had a plan
it went crazy I'm gonna pretend like
you're past ten minutes in that it felt
completely apart it was really pressing
the first time moving you dog like now I
would I would say probably not the best
plan no no no for sure I gotta kill that
time though the people must be
entertained they must I only I can save
their bloodlust
right now anyway oh you're missing shots
game this isn't some shots here hopefull
must be entertained mmm
if you keep arguing it I mean you can go
into negative points yeah I don't know
what you want from me over here I'm just
the judge I didn't make the rules wait
anyways let's do it Snuggie dude wait
[Laughter]
currently IGN is one point Gregg has won
judging this five Gregg has won sorry I
think I've missed out on something
somebody say Nick Cave yeah
wrote gladiator - so tell me what mode
is this so this is the the sniper
elimination mode you can play this co-op
basically there was a very successful
mobile game which I know we're all
inhaler for after if you have little
mortals like it's it's very fun and
basically you I think it has all the
principles of hitman which is
replayability being able to kind of mess
with the scenery in a tongue-in-cheek
kind of way while also still killing
people and they decided to bring that to
PC is a somewhat stand-alone experience
but of course you can also play it in
the full game and that's what I'm doing
here and there's a lot of like fun
little Easter eggs for me as an example
who's gonna make sure this guy doesn't
leave because back Oh perfect timing
did we get forget we're good I'm gonna
mess up your setup we just back okay so
what's happening is he's realizing that
the hippopotamus has come out of his his
depression the hippo is back and he
wants to kind of interact with his pet
while you wait for the interaction I'm
gonna announce that I'm giving I J in
1.4 dug-in mentioning hitman sniper a
game may of course by Square Enix
Montreal where my wife used to work so
that's why he gets a point totally
planned
all right so he wants some alone time
with the hippo who knows why do all 360
push when the ears go back you know it's
bad news all right that's that's my two
cents okay let's do it now here's what's
gonna happen
IGN is losing two points Oh what what
the one of the most deadly animals in
the world like I've heard this yeah
they're Devils incarnate I'm sure it
very much
sneeze nuclear syphilis all right all
right Stephen how you feel I feel great
now are these the key binds you want
yeah he's got his quick build yes he
just ran straight past suspect it don't
even care Oh what is this hiccup
patreon.com slash minor party that's the
point for everybody
point for IGN secret weapon Stephen Drew
we just picked up a poisonous flower
though had the words patreon.com/scishow
I get out all right we're gonna untie
this timber log here
so all 42 of my minutes have been just
for this mission right because you just
kept reloading your Sam after that for
the third kill you working smaller size
efficiency here we go you know this game
is too easy
oh my god tony perkins in the IGA chat
says hip bones laugh but it's a sign of
aggression as well as when they yawn and
then he says whoa so I'm not sure I can
actually knew that factoid yeah you're
so the follow-up question is anything
hippos do not a sign of aggression
because I'm pretty sure they're they're
one of the most just aggro animals the
thing about it though right you know
this works for koalas as well and I've
said this but I'm never gonna do
anything with it so I'm sharing with
everybody watching you guys right here
if somebody wants a million dollar idea
domesticate a koala and a hippo but make
them small like you know breed them get
like smaller size versions of all this
right
imagine the hippo that is the size of a
popular pig and that's as big as it ever
gets right wasn't that thing are dinner
foods in America tube in the UK there
was a real Asian people would buy micro
pigs oh yeah totally not not real yeah
but they were actually just regular pigs
but they were selling them piglets well
there is and now you have a 600-pound
pig as a pet in the IGN chat box that
says Lucy jeans laughs it's only a sign
of aggression
[Applause]
they're very important you need to avoid
them they got a lot of guns yeah yeah
take about man gotta turn on he was got
executed in the corn happen I have to do
my job and subtract 2 points i replant
what saves you got boy i hope you have a
pie autosave there you go that's it do
it yeah James yeah the top ones a
whoever was planning at 10 p.m. last
night in charge
well he didn't find any shield potions I
mean if you're just joining us ladies
and gentlemen this is IGN verse GameSpot
in a hitman to Rana we mano challenge
presented by hitman i'm greg mother from
kind of funny and I'm scoring as I go
right now IgM leads with 3 points I am
in second place with one it keeps my
head 0 stuff that was like 15 times
couple minutes ago I guess we are kind
of messing it up though yeah well it's
all over the place you know I am you put
on a show out there and I think that's
important I think we don't want to be
any table I don't know if you're gonna
win it all right security camera yeah we
go okay good then this is a lot you can
coach from the bench no big deal
sure he didn't even hear it Wow Mitchell
put your hands mentally on his hands try
and guide him sensitivity sir I can't I
can't deal now as you know I was here
recently for talk about yeah in which we
put on the wheel ghost he's caught did
you review formal if you washed it I
didn't know if you want to trade in two
points at any time I'll allow you to go
over there in ghost Steven oh wow which
means just like the hit movie ghost you
go behind you and sit on the chair
appropriately I think I'll wait for the
ghost mode just making sure
take your shirt off though please I just
want to make sure that they get you know
that royalties you know the full
experience is what does I'd be so close
exactly yeah yeah we get a copyright
strike on that whoops you're get a point
right there for that thank you nice
right no that's my singing you want my
see you know we can totally
inconspicuous I'm not sure I'm guarding
the target terrifying ski mask now in
the chat Justin Crandall on IGN's chat
says I think ideas should be should have
more points for switching between the
game and the sniper Channel that's the
president Justin as you know I didn't
give them more points for that but then
they screwed it up yeah and now since
you're whining about it I'm subtracting
oh we still love you Justin just a
little bit less do it hold back on that
impulse demon hightail it right yeah if
you haven't you can do it get out yeah
this is the final one there's no one
left to relay to oh you got it dude
you're pro shooter player he completed
giving me place in my heart place I
walked by one at PAX even if I do
Stevens thinking about it lady I'm gonna
you use a distraction at least we got oh
no what are you doing you gotta execute
her she doesn't know anything yet she
doesn't know anything all right
remaining calm he's a very calm
individual even when things get crazy
dude I saw did the guy don't mess with
the guy on the right
he sees you remember from our training
all right coach what's this oh it's a
fire alarm I don't know how to do that
what you thought about it thought about
it
Stevens he's making it up as he goes
never sure yeah yeah you guys have all
played in early times you know these
strategies you know the back story the
hippo Steve is like oh this guy doesn't
have hair
what's the bar code all about believe in
oh I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna hide in the bush yet I'm gonna
take this kind of funny patreon flower I
found
respect rose has a row don't tell me
what I'm gonna do this no just joking
joking from the front you can choke them
out you want hide them there's two
targets in here your fibro was on his
phone
look at those colored bars am I not
getting a signal at all
I'm not use these cameras all right
poison the water hide the bodies here we
go
sure go ahead
did I do it Stephen going planter do it
there you go
all right we're gonna drag this guy how
we looking on time by the way are we are
we getting interest there's no time
limit there is no we've been streamed
for 44 minutes the world isn't if
there's an hour and 15 look if it's just
even making patreon references all I'm
over here
this guy's sleeping on the job like I
said guys this games - is it though I
mean when you're this good a game as
good as Stephen is a games yeah we can't
argue at the results right we're seeing
this guy over here should come back just
to utilize you having a discussion in
the chat Justin did apologize for losing
points that suggests like I said don't
worry about it man we still love you and
like I said just a little bit less you
know well I don't agree with that snap
this guy's neck throwback to the net
it's just an app this guy's neck for
chat Bloodless we're back to three
points for IG what are you going Andreea
oh she's going back to the statue I
think I feel like you should just go for
it I think at this point you might want
to go for it I don't know my mom told me
not to give in to peer pressure
yeah that's true over in the GameSpot
chat Murphree said I'm guessing Stephen
has never played this mission before but
it's offset by Mitchell's thousands of
hours in the series so it's okay here we
go
I'm just gonna follow her please do
something so uh like ghostbusters
started from the bottom now where take
Greg up on his offer to do the ghost
thing with my shirt on this oh we're
just gonna go follow miss Andre oh that
guy's still sleeping the final kill of
course this is a real a challenge during
the IGN and GameSpot brought to you by
hitman two
[Applause]
those Carlos unprofessional which is
like the mid difficulty but even still
this is certainly like the most basic
bad experience because after this you
have things like escalations which
basically add a modifier every time so
it's like now do it only in your suit
now do it with a baseball bat now do
with this and they keep until it gets to
an absurd level and then you also have
this arrogance oh she's coming back
Mitchell what are loose touristy loose
Atari so we have we've only seen the
announcement of the the first elusive
target which is Sean Bean zombie and
it's coming on November 20th but I
actually didn't mess around much with
the elusive targets I think you're
probably they're just so basically you
get its you're connected online and you
get one shot to kill this person and you
have to nail it and if you fail like we
have done on the stream you're out you
never get it again yeah I would like if
you can kill him in a multitude of Sean
Bean desk ways all right lady I think
you just gotta go you gotta go forward
Steven I know you talk a lot of trash to
her and they just never do there's a lot
of all right lady we've practiced some
pretzels that always gets me to drink
well he's gonna go she's gonna go don't
worry I don't know I think you have an
SMG right there and I think there's like
three or four people I think we should
give him a time limit this is - yeah
quite a while sorry
IGN also in favor of the time away oh
wow turning on their own also we're
never gonna play ghost mode if you just
keep doing the games about having fun
[Music]
rising to the challenge five minutes
silenced pistol and just decided to back
to him
well it's hey When in Rome does the
halfway point of round one here I Gina's
four points GameSpot one point Bregman
at one point can you win this what
happens if you win you know what I think
I brought a gift for the winner but I
win you got myself and so I guess I walk
away with it it may be a big bummer it's
kind of like a white elephant where you
know you put it in but you eventually
want it back cuz it's your own thing
you understand yeah no it's you're
familiar with that generate elephant
Ayami
yes my pictures yes it was in fact I got
I got it without so like the the
tradition is he put a $20 bill in there
cuz it's a $20 which would make your
picture sure I don't know what that the
price would be on it then but anyway my
point is you get a $20 bill in it and I
just got the picture I never got 20
bucks
Darren Brazil you owe me sir but the
picture is the real gift yes it is it
stood it stood on my desk proudly for a
whole year and somebody who had the Greg
Miller photo from the white elephant
it's it's from my First Holy Communion
every wow that's very cute
no it's actually really creepy scary you
get one point now IG that's five points
right you're going first
Jesse's reading off get up there Jess
all right here we go are you a complain
that they touch your computer is it
always tougher you know this fine your
skin again they're good or it's gonna be
fine Oh didn't reset it or anything for
me I got a start over here you know what
you know what okay that's rude
did she know by that you losers waiting
for that you're back to four calls this
has taken time this is just killing time
can someone vamp for me that's what this
whole streams about her
first gamespot it hit me to mono e mono
channels brought to you by hitman to
those good vamp it crashed it right
first job 1.4 game spot for saying I
nailed it really good we got to win
these points back so it's currently then
I Jean is three points GameSpot has two
points Greg what's the order for you
guys chassis is gonna lead off so
chastity then Ben than me but we're
gonna have to do some shuffling yeah cuz
Mitchell did my kill I can't believe is
fun so I don't want people now have to
go through the same thing
yeah right here's the back-up plan line
and I'm in Wow look at this wall then
we're all on camera Oh up here it's
alive
wait hold on I said I was gonna keep on
their toes now now go to the GoPro GoPro
involved while we watch all this I guess
I'm still my toes up to the challenge I
think I can set me up PC gaming what a
joke you always one point for this
sabotage yes
you planted malware was on this computer
is what kids want you crash the game I
don't know how he points out I know you
all lost one point for playing up here
should we play in getting trophies
station actually I'm getting myself one
point for that references welcome so now
I'm tied for the lead with IG this is
get it we can all see your notes what
does it say there oh no says IGN wins no
matter what no that's a comfy for you no
one ever talks about floors here
probably cuz people online it that often
it's fair how much time have you spent
in this room
how much time have I spent in this I
gene studio jeez Louise
a lot of thousands yeah
something like that right you figure up
at noon game scoop and then when i was
here i don't--hey I never moved in here
I think beyond was still until my closet
yeah I apparently been playing indeed a
lot yeah so now the nice thing is it's
like 33 degrees Fahrenheit in here
perfect yeah which i think is great a
lot of people complain a baboon your now
similarly you know it's obviously the
lights heat everything up there's a lot
of movement body so like do you come to
work out here because it's so it's
actually a great idea like there's all
this junk over there if you look we
don't need it sure it could be used for
some important production stuff for
shows sure I'm just not aware of but
that could be a big that's the thing too
is I feel like that junk corner was here
when I was here like I feel like that's
just always been the junk corner well I
can't fault Alexi oh he's very neat he's
a professional
everybody likes Alexi I get it he's the
best yeah really
no problem I think we're back in the
game we're back in the game
alright and don't break it this time
right chastity alright got it got it
I believe in you it worked this time I
was allowed to pick up the crowbar and I
got some boys just picking up stuff for
my friends you know team play team play
I'm looking at my team looking at from a
team so you guys are a team game spot
you all have a synchronized run here you
know you know what kills you're doing
and how you're doing in charge yeah
pretty much
unless Lucy has to change her is up
because of Mitch well or are you just
doing it slightly differently I'm gonna
change it okay I've done the other one
at home yeah but it's not as well
rehearsed so if anything it might just
have to go to the edgy MPC yeah I'm
gonna go to the IGN piece someone check
I think Alexia got electrocuted
it's Winnie's GameSpot pcs that's what's
going on who's wrong we didn't bring
these I saw you bring that one in here
don't pin that yeah there's our PC
yeah I'll check it out you get up
through drivers you know okay sweet four
in the background as well you said that
thing about PC gaming and it's got me
quite salty however I did I for the
first time in my life I was like you
know what in video xx atti it's
expensive it's ridiculous but it's for
me for the first time I'm gonna go for
top of wine got it broke in like five
days
what yeah yeah you got a point for that
you get a point for being honest about
PC but hey that's difficult but I would
say the rewards I'll take this point
back the rewards as a pointer gone
absolutely worth the investment the time
investment I do know that face PC gaming
for life folks now I'd use unless point
unless God wore it got a word fantastic
fair enough
right I'm gonna try this again how are
you feeling right now the wheels are
coming off put on yet like we're we're
still getting started it's like a
time-traveling thing where there's
nothing back to kill you guys before you
could ever start exactly mitchell's over
there he has no problems with a PC so
work to me alright I'm back in alright
here we go
this time it's for real I can still hear
you Lucy wasn't talking smack exactly
just like we wanted like haha we did it
we got it from her bedside yeah I think
that'd be funny if they does fine Alexei
Alexei Oh get the point for setting you
know we're tired right we're all all
three of us Todd and games first
I know currently IGN GameSpot Aleksey
are tied with one Greg has two points oh
I'm coming out of nowhere on this one
you know so I'm at this engineer's house
and I'm gonna steal his outfit so I can
get to the caves
no chastity I'm gonna be stealthy what's
up how did you discover your kill did
you go through and do a bunch of
different ones and I learned three kills
for my mark just in case I wasn't sure
at first who I was going up against and
then I found out last night I found out
last night that I was going up against
my boyfriend James Duggan and that he
had the same exact kill as me collusion
is there you knew you were supposed to
talk about what killed you were doing so
for context that guy just got hit by a
submarine and hesitation a terrible day
okay now it's worse down there we got
some piranha action like a very nice
wonderful and I got my key card and I've
got my disguise can you just help me
living in the life it's time to go to
work
terminate - Eska efficiency hey what's
up alright and that guy now that guy's
gonna tell the bartender to give me a
key to the basement so I can sneak in
without having go through the mission
sports Almanac she's in the chat on IGN
Steven the dude says loving all the
hitman love smiley emoji with sunglasses
smiley emoji of sunglasses smiley emoji
with sunglasses I salute all hitman fans
reading this Steven we salute you you
get a point
Reggie were doing it
the dude Thank You loose we're doing
that you get a point as well so now I'm
gonna talk to the scarf tenders gonna
give me a key to the business check out
this bar
there's a famous tattoo artist here
thank you that true as well are you are
you making it up
no in the story he's the main storyline
I think she's doubling down on her
fantasy of you guys playing through this
game is like Groundhog Day but you say
that that's exactly what it's like and
it's so much fun to like exist in a
place where you know exactly what's
gonna happen what's the point yeah you
can experiment like you're talking my
when they add in the modifiers to change
it you just immediately oh okay well
there's this here and I can do that
hello
what kind of comes together in that
sense Eric green on the GameSpot YouTube
says only coins dress for Ben
Ben's not wrong you want to be buried on
that okay
sheep it's a you you can control
literally any character in the entire
game with just a coin you tell them to
go anywhere you want
move them around tell them to just do
whatever they'll do it oh yeah
they're very hot is it like some kind of
commentary on cash rules everything
around everyone great creepers well I
guess in that sense to be I'm in the
underground caves now this is the
submarine area with the plan chastity
I'm gonna use that subs to kill my mark
okay right in front of me whole
submarine yeah whole submarine so guys
what the dots can recognize me I'm just
gonna sneak right behind him Danette Dan
ladies and gentlemen you're watching IG
and verse game thought in a mano a mano
hit man to challenge brought to you by
hitman two we're going for another hour
or so tell me
was it I haven't got caught yet oh
you're good all right and making sure
everybody realizes she doesn't yeah I'm
really good at the game everybody just
let me know okay
stand up I mean while Mitchell trying to
undo the Voodoo he did this is why I'm
gonna have them call their boss so you
can come down and check out this sub
this takes a bit of times gonna hang out
take your time don't worry
again there's no rush everything yeah
you guys have to professional websites
feel like you got to be nice to the chat
I don't do that I'll just have dinner I
wasn't waiting around okay so what did
you do there chess so I just tinkered
with it so that it's gonna go way too
hard and just completely fly off those
two and they're talking to me they think
I'm the engineer that got injured by
this sub before and I'm like yeah that
was me
but in reality that's the guy you killed
yeah my bad I fed them to the fishes I
kinda want after you broke isn't that I
want to see hitman go to 11 in terms of
putting on people's clothes and becoming
them like I want to see you knock
somebody's wife out just put on her
dress with her ten years exactly and I
can execute your mark I think that's
real commitment I think you said you
wanted hitman go to good like the mobile
games yeah yeah well I want that too
that's another great square enix
Montreal reference I'm going to point to
loose rail
early GameSpot three points Greg to IGN
Alexia and Steven the dude I'll tighten
this up a little bit just in the chat
says chastity is legit
thank you oh he's coming over
Oh specific answer specify around
measurements here we go
why'd you get right in front of there
sir it's of course a relay challenge
once chastity kills her mark do we want
to go same order
no is in like we've we've had to switch
up a plan yeah we're dressing on the fly
sure how comfortable are you with it
because I changed it all on you so you
can call it tell me don't get further
that's a good one that's the point for
gamespot I was a good kill thank you
thank you all right here comes the relay
switch over there are they going to that
GoPro cam look at it very clean thank
you now it breaks my heart I was a
doctor point from you spot of course the
tag has to happen with them still
anchored to the cam show all your
progress all right gamespot in the lead
with three
Greg behind with two through your tie
with IGN Alexia and Stephen the dude in
the YouTube chat
watch out for that get you're gonna get
out now in the YouTube chat Adama Wu
says Greg as you were scoring yourself I
think it's only fair you have to try at
let's at least the sniper mode I'm gonna
give you negative one point for bringing
it up
that's a rough one for you that's gonna
be hard for you to call it crawl out of
oh you want to go back the other way
which is the opposite side the cave
again if you're joining us they are
allowed to coach from the bench that is
a lamb from behind here all the way over
the right yeah like past that blue door
that one yep there you go this is
because we've been adjusting yes so this
isn't the order you were originally
batting it wasn't even the kill I was
gonna do so why do it Weiss why should
ye get crazy because Mitchell did my
kill why do you care but you do a better
Mitchell you kind of show the people
more of the game no you don't job don't
you mean I oh let them worry about that
you're here to win aren't you it's like
when I camp in a video game and I was
like stop camping it's boring I'm like
I'm in straight again yeah that's right
good alright that's a point again for
them you're back to four points okay so
you're back in town now
alright can I use the poison that you
picked up yep we can use it for anything
do you want to go for the backpacker
cool laundry cases what are the scoring
criteria is they obviously are going for
Silent Assassin it's whatever I want it
to be Audrey you don't like it
unsubscribe from both their YouTube
channels that come to kind of fun okay
how many pushups for a point oh my god
what does a bargaining thing you know
that's getting it wedding this is 1.25
not that many Oh knock out 25 points I
don't know why he's Stephen you can't
set the bar I have to do it I think Greg
should should issue the challenge you
can't say push-ups knowing that everyone
else
the real question is how many shirtless
push-ups
I'm thinking how many squats do you sift
to you needed 20 and I did 21 with a me
on my back he goes to the gym
religiously sure now I can barely walk
the next day and had no form for my
squats hey way to win
exactly exactly that thing I'm more fit
than you system you can't wife's mark
says Greg you're usually nice to the
Chad but you can feel free to be mean to
me if you want
WAIS mark I could never mean to you
you're doing great in that chat hold it
down for me is he up there so he's the
one in the colourful tie-dye
oh is that guy on it oh god it's not
that one is he gonna see me you might
see you now crouch down oh you're so
good at coming back
you've got think it's fine Mitchell
fixed it everybody around emboss you
flash goodbuy how to get the glue the
operating to get it yeah he's crouching
down the stairs as I go straight out
that way
yeah so what'd I miss IRA listen listen
yes there are folks in the chat who have
more points of interest to be fair
there's one it was a mechanic at the
beginning oh this guy yeah yeah he has
it but you have to take him down
there's a bin directly your left yeah
this woman as well she's just gonna sit
for a while as soon as she walks back to
the dock then go for it yeah I get to
live another day you go not talk to him
talk to him
I think it makes you talk to him first
no no you talked to the guy English oh
the shop they're falling apart they
shouldn't shaken up their strategies no
I think you still take him down you can
get it from memory I don't want to be
interrupted to this guy you will witness
it you're talking fine we thought Luce
do you know she's doing she knew she
knew exactly
okay let's just you know she's got I'm
sorry about your wife nice that was good
okay well done clean engine you enough
to use your can of soda at all my nice
refreshing drink exam gonna enjoy okay
loop's are you feeling confident I'm
feeling good yeah feeling good is he
here
he should be
see where is he Oh
using your inch might be downstairs in
the store yeah I think he is let me
Cerrito you can turn on the wrong guy
that's fine yeah oh the other guy's
gonna come yeah he's coming in you knock
him out too and put him in check I'm
just good idea according to fine that is
it that is it for you what am asleep
okay right
Stephen getting into it even though it's
not our pleasure thanks you know cuz
Lucy is awesome that's cuz she's she's
nailing it yeah leaving our witnesses
wait I can't change into his outfit but
I can put the alarm on again she's that
can take over the backpacker comes back
up you could do the same strat just turn
on that alarm hang outside the door
[Music]
Lucy in the chat killin it Lucy Brandon
Dao says come on England
just like England they will beat the USA
on Thursday yes like the overwatch World
Cup which was a dizzying high and then
the US was definitively better but I my
mentions for a few days much I
appreciate it when I went to tweet it
and you said yeah that's funny go ahead
I want to turn off the alarm yeah the
drug busts you put him inside under the
closet - if you want to be absolutely
like you know was just that's just clear
up yeah a nice clean attention
everything cool why isn't he wearing
shoes he's really getting into that
hippie vibe it's the real Silent
Assassin
so if I take a left there's the entrance
with the two guards in front of it right
in front of you like to the left back
around back around oh yeah so I was
gonna look into that but then there is
like a training session yeah the
strategy yeah just walk up to them
they'll let you through but you have the
job I have to drop your guns my okay
well he's not gonna I'm not gonna mess
you up then just leave the gun in the
bushes it'll be fun yeah I'll pick it up
on my way back they play hitman bad
committee they have a whole roll out of
bed it's paying off right now of course
here in the IG inverse game a spot
hitman two mano a mano challenge brought
to you by hitman mr. GameSpot four
points to my to the one for an IGN
Alexios diva the dude and then I did
leave out Adamo in the chest yeah he
liked ha yeah you know I'm really
role-playing this I'm doing security
escort come on like that that's cool
NPCs hate it when you're too close I
also hate radio okay now I'll preface
with this is from YouTube chat I don't
agree with it it's the juxtaposition
here that I enjoy interesting your
friendly neighborhood spider-man says I
hate British accent spider made roughly
not friendlies in your name not the
spider-man okay exactly right hashtag
mad like spider but not my side of it
see we're just having a nice little
stroll through yeah she's going through
this mine I do you gotta do like a
hippie boys plant it on the table new
see how the chats doing there's a chair
what's gonna sit yeah hey shut up sit
shout out to either your friendly
neighborhood spider-man or the IGN miles
who deleted that message dude I glued
that back together
now you play the waiting game alright
yeah oh yeah that's what hippies do bad
no let me an interesting family feud
what hippies do best waiting game oh
yeah hey
okay she's having a rough time what
happened so I spiked his cocaine despite
the drug busts I confirmed down nice all
right that's the negative three now been
doing me to drop you if you want to do
the courtesy drop off I'm done cocaine
all right just say a little bit of
coordination I think I know Iran it's
the other way yeah stay hidden and then
you can hand off they're like The
Avengers right for any things and you
guys are like the x-men you use like
Wolverine today pretty but it's
backwards let's tear mark you good yeah
there we go okay there's a gun there's
the gun we're good okay guys the real a
handoff I'm gonna wait to stand up cuz I
learned from yes GameSpot mano-a-mano
challenge and hitman 2 presented my
hitman 2 continues been taking the stage
right now
gamespot commanding lead of four points
my two to IGN's one Alexios one Steven
the dudes one and then downloads
negative all you gotta do if you want to
lose all your points as mentioned PC
gaming
Manickam it all goes away so I've been
it's a great point
IGN's back to zero dude beat nests in
the Chad seem the dude and Alexia out of
he went straight to the mansion nice
he's uh got him cameras slippery cameras
kind of difficult to deal with sneaking
around the mansion been a quiet man
methodical yeah hold every mean he knows
what he wants he knows his strategies
here he's laser focused he's terrifying
to say the least
[Laughter]
there's a drought dude come on someone
saved them from the drought there we go
that's my guy
there he is music kind of it blaze I
know that's the foster turning on music
goodnight get his hot get his hat yes
we've got it good job hmm figure right
and the garbage with the flies camera
sure we're good we're gonna medal your
solid it just stay underneath it you are
smart
don't waste the ammo there's a lot of
people at the mansion yeah there's a lot
of guards no they'll have the white dog
it's a scary place to be but our boy
Dwayne is very very brave everything
about how weird bushes are like somebody
at some point was like that Bush doesn't
like that Bush I'm gonna get a lot of
bushes and I want to do this dance team
bushes I'm gonna shape I mean today
sometimes I think about Edward
Scissorhands yeah yeah oh yeah you stay
right all the time like if you never
could anything with notice that there's
gonna nonsense yeah my beautiful army of
course you did you made a beautiful art
yeah I once saw a ballet of Edwards it's
wild I made about this yet
one time he didn't hear it who wants
money this guy does you know he does get
the money yeah like this pink shirt it's
about to be mine
it's a nice salmon you're just going
through them right yes so this is back
to your theory that the coins the most
powerful weapon of the game oh it's not
forget the coin get the oh he leaves the
gun oh wait where I'm going excuse me
coins coins are all you need it's true
despite these 50 items in his inventory
the camera operator if I'm in the
security room I see him going off one by
one
yeah yeah we gotta get out so because we
had to adjust our strategy our rotation
is off yeah and now I've got to wait for
our guy to show up oh man it's almost
like you should place my permission I
was one up show you on this night from
[Applause]
not of interest to Ben jacket prophet of
regret on each of come and says Ben is a
flippin Pro yes would have to agree see
here's what I'm gonna do though I'm
gonna knock off a point
haha yeah I feel like you guys are so
locked into this strategy that you can't
DV we wait further come run you're
buckin hitman two not an hour ago and
his name was
you're the final kill to Steven it you
can also stalk him around his route yeah
I'm so excited talking about Steven I'm
giving IG Nepal do you want a poisonous
cocaine for fun oh I got you poison
oh no two things a poison to not see you
so do this right in front of you it's
not marked it is no he will still see
you suspicious he'll see you being weird
Willy London color outside the lines for
Street
well he don't see you there's a guy do
it Limpy gonna do the poison coke hey
you're wearing the same shirt is me guy
alright take a look at ya he's gonna do
it
that's a point Oh poison oak poison
we're gonna get more points during
GameSpot Stern than we will in ours
oh this cocaine is unhealthy now okay
follow them to the bathroom shoot a bit
yeah just come on
if the people this is just a poor guy
carrying something that I need that only
furthers the argument to just human men
but I think that's the only thing feels
Nick it's fine to do one of the best
things that money here it's another
point for bed I want to see you behind
the scenes of how he got that noise see
here honey it's a fire - guess we don't
even need this guy we're just gonna put
it back in here thing we're here for
them is this love letter because we're
uh we're not going for not just like a
straight-up murder kill we're going for
like a like an emotional kill - it's a
very important thing there are multiple
dimensions to this kill all right you
sadist sorry wait I like Julia Child I
like there's a lot going on here mmhmm
yeah we're good just get out of here
nice it's good good good joint yeah
clean break so he picked up a love
letter from one Hector Delgado who is
the brother of the guy who isn't
who used to date our third mark miss
Andrea Martinez scoop get a little bit
of backstory so he's gonna deliver that
love letter to her distract her get her
all emotional and then take her out of
course ladies and gentlemen you're
watching IG and verse GameSpot presented
by hitman - they're playing hitman -
sure it all makes sense you do some
flexing yeah I just in your shot do you
know I'm in here give me my shot you
mean like my shot Aleksey oh there it is
good I'm not even literally talking to
you last I have my hearty let's go to
the gym rats huh you're popping off well
I wrote it makes me violent oh I like
that shot that's fine it's fine we
remember this well from Stevens playing
with this bush has made famous by Steve
it's a good Bush yeah for winning plays
at home
he's not gonna do any quick Oh who's
there searching for okay yeah it's
almost like T my Jeanne thought of a way
to fill this time by running around the
house three times
damage how much the Hitman - have you
played at home I've been oh nice yeah
I'm just still going back to it all the
difference after yeah so I mostly have
been going back to it in preparation for
the stranger yeah but definitely looking
to go back to it and check out some more
of the story kills and stuff like that
well that was the thing right with him
it's the first year what I gonna go
hitman season 1 hitting the first hit
man for the reboot or whatever well they
did such a great job of giving you a
stream of content right so then even if
you beat the story you came back like
you guys are talking about the targets
forever yeah and there's more content I
feel like the game starts the elusive
targets like that's where really like
everything is just she's just downstairs
here we go we had a kill screen coming
up guys
hitman two kills for you come on over
looking at all right thank you thanks
for getting the reference hey you know
that's another point
I literally from literally every day
fantastic I say that Donkey Kong kill
screen commentary every day
what are my instructions mr. Martinez
said a realization while I was doing
this earlier
agent 47 hasn't been wearing this shirt
long enough to get sweat on it okay so a
hundred percent another guys yeah
gross that's disgusting commitment its
commitment in the hygiene chat a young
boy named Destin lagari pops up it says
I like the part where gamespot lost to
IGN again and then did that emoji with
the tongue sticking out so I gene loses
a point that was kill the day so far I'm
gonna take that love letter just so I
can remember it I gotta get out of here
you can make up the boat escape goat
escape or you could go out in style
you got a mac-10 worship no cigar says
game swap out to Merc IGN duggan a great
game of though ha ha ha man game respect
get this the other but we're talking
about down here it's very good at video
games oh you're biased
Oh
keep going to the next dock I don't want
to be I don't want to be sentimental but
I do feel like
gamespot deserve this someone chastity
was just putting in hours I was doing I
was like nose to the grindstone in
battlefield five but every time I look
over man she's just killing fo someone
in here hiding their bodies oh come on
now yeah around the other side is fun
I'm just I'm not gonna stop talking
about how great PC gaming is all right
zero points for ideas in row if you are
just joining us ladies and gentlemen
this is IGN verse GameSpot in the hitman
two mano-a-mano challenge all the points
are made up I assign them as I see fit
and a lot of people are mad about that
in the chat currently the standings are
as such GameSpot has six points IGN has
zero points I have two points all right
Alexia was Steven the dude in the chat
have one point and then damn Oh still
has negative one point in the YouTube
chat at least we're not last anybody's
game still here as we are going for a
little bit longer 30 more minutes or so
we need to come to a victor of course
round 2 is ghost mode are you all
familiar with ghost mode yeah yeah
explain it to me
so ghost mode is essentially you sounded
like you really wanted to do so there's
a clone of agent 47 if you will from an
alternate dimension
this isn't canon this is my
interpretation of it I love it already
you're getting a point for it you bring
it all turn into missions members yes
have any whiter somehow the Nagant 47
he's this alabaster and basically your
existing in these two instances of the
game target gets assigned in both
instances and you have to execute that
target as fast as possible gosh it's all
about speed it's all about not being
seen if you're seeing you lose a point
if you get killed you don't lose a point
but if you kill somebody who's not the
target you also lose a point and first
person to five points wins gotcha
so then this is when you play head to
head who started me one this is another
relay race okay this is the same thing
but scantly the couch until you've been
tagged not the bug for the person's been
tagged the hand attached to the but race
tag and after every kitchen
for every kill you have to cycle out
yeah yeah great so IG and who are you
starting with I'll go first
Oh get over there oh yeah this is the
one we've been waiting for the pros I
appreciate that you couldn't go up there
and fight him no it's it's a reunion
they used to do streams together I'd
like to see this gta5 let's play so some
of my favorite stuff oh they were so
good you can asunder I kept fighting
each other they set it up remember this
is IGN verse game to you mano-a-mano
challenge brought to you by hitman two
available Nalin you can go and kill
people your own house and then you play
the game just kidding don't kill people
that's not what people want to happen in
any fashion Oh
standings right now GameSpot six points
hygiene one embarrassing yeah
embarrassing for you guys you know I
mean to say Craig Harris lot of lobbies
we lost at least three points because of
PC PC game it for life baby contract
it's a harsh break
oh wait a second jump into five this is
boring of course so doesn't really
matter whatever happens see there you
see right there
Ben doesn't even understand PC game
that's why he gets a point seven seven
points for game spot zero for IG and
it's rough out there excellent Greg
Miller too though we'll see if I can
pull it out more interesting demo can
you ever get out of the negative one
zone alright I'm gonna invite you
Desilu Gary who lost you guys a point in
the chat chimes in with Real Talk miss
Bennett chastity heart miss you too
that's a point for IGN
Destin's bring in the back you guys any
but I did except it's loading and here
we are we're in oh wait a second like I
got a oh my planning I can pick my suit
but there's nothing here there's nothing
in my suit I did alright here we go
oh man oh no none of this is what we
want it exactly
came to this party dressed in the same
way this is real embarrassing look good
you look better all right guys we get it
you used to scream together and there is
no rivalry that's not what the people
want they want blood exactly now it's
just gonna be horrible in the IG YouTube
chat MD says guys it's 4 a.m. in India
here we go ready 10 seconds make it up
on the ground see you later
it's 2 ayah they understood that
GameSpot had to leave so they got a head
start on that one that's how that works
remember this is a real AC they every
kill they have to tag out oh ok how many
points will winning this count for who
knows we'll decide later
I don't care man I'm blending into the
crowd is that how we're playing this
yeah yeah we're doing it I don't know if
my didgeridoo though you need to did
your there I do so it's part of the plan
all right well there's a lot more people
here to witness this than I thought
there would be so I just walked past the
guard who's yelling at me about coming
upstairs
no time for that here we go what up dude
and dad's gotta kill no but are you
gonna get seen though
it has to stay unnoticed for us or oh
yeah oh but the difference is I'm being
shot at and it hurts me it hurts me when
you shoot me with bullets put that gun
away that's a real bad call I got
flashbang these guys duggan death means
nothing because i had no idea it's
coming down to good news i'm close to
the target now why are they picking
targets in to see if people yeah after
we just have to deal with it miami level
well check this oh my gosh oh my gosh
thanks man gotta count what is this Oh
didn't count he's downstairs
oh man gauging don't I'm always on the
ball oh my god in front of everybody
this is uh this is mad at least man is
messing this up as hard as I am yeah man
it's kind of hit my knee this guy's guys
look okay
I did this on purpose now we got oh
that's that's a point for IGN right
there you know what I'm going this way
entertainment 101 dress in a mascot so
you try to kill people
I love mascot suits you might want to
hide that body yeah okay
you know the jig's up they know
everything what the scared me I'm pretty
inconspicuous all right now that's
interesting James play the mascot Oh No
worked on the other side
hi Gina's 2 points game spotted six all
right it's time yeah come on up here
what's up know your next kill regardless
of if you actually get caught or not you
have to relay out oh I'm not gonna get
caught okay my bob we're good okay I'll
back off
we got it screwdriver lethal syringe
that's we're gonna do what's exactly
what you build
and we're just gonna we're just gonna
stick them in the middle of this crowd
no one's gonna care
[Music]
I didn't kill him
hygiene you have to relay out chaos it's
no longer matters you can't you got a
lethal syringe though
dad do you keep the syringe after you
die though let's go those the only those
who don't shoot me with a flamingo suit
hey you're that you're the hitman pro
you not any image alright I did all that
to set you up so you can show people how
great you are exactly thanks I
appreciate it you have to change your
outfit I need to find somewhere where
people aren't shooting me for that yeah
you were just throwing caution to the
wind with the bullets here Ben got a
kill there now he does that means the
regardless of this he needs to tag out I
think there's gonna be six oh thank god
this guy's looking for you in that place
though very interesting uh-huh they're
gone totally missed it though alright oh
did you get it it's still anybody's game
well again these points don't matter my
points man my points matters fair enough
alright that's it I do Mac - I don't
belong here just tryin to find another
ghost box
chasidy died on top of those arms I did
die in his arms that was Stephen the
dude says in the chat so fun to watch a
plan failed disastrously agreed and
that's why you're getting a point back
in the game
Mitchell how you feel right now oh not
super confident but you know I'm dealing
he's doing the singing steady turtle
strat I feel good about it yeah you're
behind this help oh yeah hi nothing to
see here just uh flamingos walking
around get on the mapper on that this is
amol coccyx
yes so they're those boxes that have
random items in them and that kind of
has some matter replay value with the
targets and stuff like that you can get
some really really powerful stuff
including that ghost coin yeah which
actually influences the opponent's
universe my understanding of it is
correct
I learned this by trying to grab my
didgeridoo it wasn't there it's
fantastic
there's nothing here chassis get out
yeah oh no targets nope IgM lying I like
that that's a boy I think that's your
chance Mitch he's on the stairs oh no
did someone see her
do you notice oh yeah here a real point
[Applause]
didn't go anywhere you want
crawler over the desk knock over Jesse's
computer get in there see mr. Barrett is
that the tag we can go all right I've
played literally zero seconds of this
game yeah we're in Morpheus you all
right Stephen you're good right here
nobody play cool head to the cubicle
across the hall
go now in control hold ctrl see if I
want you to look for Ghost Box so you
can get a new weapon or something I
think you just get across the racetrack
you know what I'm gonna defer to you
mental
chesty I switched outfits out of the
flamingo's yep Steven if you go all the
way to stress there's gotta be a bridge
I'll get my chastity
don't knock pepper there's a little way
to find out no they wouldn't mood just
motions with a hammer getting these
hitches you see that PC gaming lying
he's selling his soul for boys I feel
like you should deduct a point Wow
I'll tell you what you just doubled your
score that means it's tied six-six
IGN GameSpot I'm bringing up the rear
with three points Alexio one point
Steven the do two points interesting
Damo negative one
no witnesses
see that that sky bridge over there
whatever you wanna call it
you know I'm going there gentle chess
it's good yeah nobody saw no there
should be a door that look I'll let you
in there yeah yeah yes good oh yeah yeah
no get up oh it's great thank you
we're on the board all right pause here
because we all know the target is you're
gonna get a new target yeah yeah that's
gets you where it's at what's on your
side go there go you got an advantage
here
oh my sees you Stephen what's confidence
level at right now zero would he doesn't
have a single shot it's on it's on your
site no that's the racetrack
might be in the building in the front
back well I feel good about Stephens
odds here as long as he doesn't complete
my screw it up I think he's in the
garage you gotta go you gotta go
underground so keep going past those
stairs don't go in the stairs yeah keep
going past there that's fine don't worry
about that guy there you go now I Jean
started this place in this teamwork it's
been GameSpot's trademark hmm oh the
underground
goods are setting in there's a panic
setting in Boise they're getting louder
right there is no are you clear I think
again what didn't even worry hell he's
getting the ghost box body found huh
okay this is good disguise yeah okay
you don't get spot it's killing just do
it man where's a cute cute yeah break
that neck he's gotta be oh god see me to
play with fire yeah I just routes to
trapping dude you're good you putting
him in the handicapped spot there that's
bad man all right all right
Wow Steven oh I'm impressed
thank you Greg I am impressed with you
they're actually trying to keep open
eyes universe games but six point six
points uh graphics crew Alexio remember
you need to add mean there are three
points I do too
Damo with negative one do that for us
every grade
in the chat Fernando Hernandez says Lucy
James thanks there might be a new if you
need a new disguise there's one of the
coat-check wait how do I get to coach I
go around the corner Alexia I saw the
shoe for me thank you behind you of
course this has played best of father
wait yeah yeah we're we're we're good
you're good well it's very true
all right I got to get a different
disguise this may be just the place
chefs can go most places in this yeah
you're good everybody with a scalpel I
don't want any of these things
Oh do I dare weapons old axes
I think they'll notice an axe Oh in the
IgH at sewing up says cut someone's face
off and wear it Wow
Sully you need to go to sir wait wait a
me climax says okay castor Troy and for
that gets a point
face-off Griffin good very nice he's
fine all right
/ it's over how far is it on the other
side here nothing all right
my buddy is my wife I feel like I'm
about this nobody nobody Tommy there's
nobody back there am i forever curse
they always be seeing me oh wait I
didn't snap his neck
oops I think it might be too late yeah
we lost oh I lost it dammit alright next
kill regardless of point or not you I am
domain Minnie tag I don't like you're
not that far away okay no I'm gonna take
that guy who's cast yeah
like the even wider version okay this
isn't gonna get it back yeah keeping it
interesting a clean reset here Mitch
there you go that's another pro strat no
one it's lost you might need a new
costume definitely do alright let's see
get my bearings
there's chests down there come on
a wife's mark in the chat says plus one
for Greg for singing I'll take it what
he says you know it's on the board
alright what the IGN GameSpot - mono e
mono challenge currently I can GameSpot
bolt tied at 6 cool I've worked closer
with for who I stick with me Aleksey oh
and Amy climax tied for one Stephen the
dude has to DA mom still negative one
rough out there GameSpot chats doing Oh
Mitchell you've got this man
I believe in you right at me Tracy their
chanted for best games but yet I always
won the bathroom this is great yeah you
got to do it quick dude Ben's got his
clothes come on give me another target
for three please stop shooting one and
eliminate
I thought we get to find points fashion
yeah I guess you're really mad it's just
really easy to get caught you doing
great Ben thank you keep it up and
you're doing great buddy
thank you again Ben silent you know I
mean everything's quiet ease methodical
he knows what he's doing he's getting
into the character you know my
self-esteem is fine but it'd be nice to
hear you're doing great Mitchell - yeah
you do really well thanks I want to know
before you came back Thunder kiyah OH
and the chat said bring it bring it back
Mitch oh that's my wife sorry I hope
[Laughter]
that's cool this guy's you guys okay
illusion but has it been a lot of like
face the ghost time so I feel like we
could probably you know it's one to one
is the IGN versus GameSpot you're not
gonna go for the dude dad ear guy we're
good friends just dancin you know
getting a little Pat's going who are
these idiots
yeah there's just no good we have no
tools we're just basically waiting for
me day to place build a build a 1x1 map
there's nothing to look at in there he's
thinking don't you ever do that you look
a reflection yep I found over at
Benjamin's
all right let's think of something else
are you doing here Mitchell thinking on
the floor I think we may need to rip the
band-aid off that is this NPC and just
go for it because this could be a point
though this is both not very common
Mitchell just joking out random people
he's gonna eliminate all witnesses in
any way you can one by one
do it buddy I believe in the middle of
the field snap his neck need to rip the
band-aid off as they say I feel like the
chap must think we're bad at video game
[Laughter]
nothing but respect justice guys I feel
like we've played so much that all the
ghosts chest circumference guys gonna
say that we were like nun over there at
all
and to be clear yeah in the chat being
very nice a gentleman from Russia said
hello from Russia how was your day and
everybody said hi James Guerrero says I
want kind of funny to win change thank
you how many places are you just
representing kind of funny sure kind of
funny just getting all the wins this
game which is a guaranteed oh you're not
gonna get any time you meant to get in
the trash can oh no don't kill the NPC
we need that point to face a lot a lot
there's dead people everywhere
take us home gun well this is opposite
I'm looking for looking for a new outfit
try not to get got by trespassing into
areas hidden God you know bonds guy Ben
jacket catchphrase get up on that guy
okay God don't kick you out get up on
the guy
remember ladies gentlemen next point
wins this since we could not get to five
my chamber Steve what is happening hit
me into oh my god
such shame Mitchell electing to go to
the aquarium to check out the fish check
out of here it is a very pretty room now
the gamer Chad actually comes through
all right Mitchell now it's your time to
shine man you're gonna get a new target
here this could be it
read all those matchups all the mistakes
lost hours of practice for nothing it's
gonna get up right now how far is it
dirty [ __ ] it's pretty far away yeah
are you far too bad I can't I'm pretty
far away okay really finished even
playing fields Irish in the IG and chat
says hello from India Indonesia how is
your day hello you lose a point for that
you know that was already something
somebody else did
you're just trying to copy the Russian
guy and I'm not about that life at least
he's on the board the aquarium
it's a nice room would you for lunch
today nothing you just doing it
Mitchell's going for it ninja straight
to the face
ninja starred and no witnesses around to
see I am nice job that brings IGN back
to six and here we go let's do the final
tabulation here to decide who is one i J
inverse GameSpot and the hit man mono e
mono challenge vigilic been fantastic
performers it's come and join us
oh so Robin thank you I have it as IGN
six points GameSpot six points who Greg
four points then there was a motion I
didn't say it that said we should
tabulate all the extra points and they
go to Greg it kind of funny yeah so that
would be one freight from anticlimax
negative one for demo that knocks them
out i rich had negative one Alexio had
one that knocks them out so then it's
two points bringing it back to six so
it's a three-way tie we bring out the
presents this is what the winner was
going to get and it's all of us it's a
cake
duck on it and it's got the cake and I
made it myself and it didn't come from
the safe way down this tree so much fun
look at this just get up in group hug
just like this cake represents the
Internet there's enough internet for all
people to eat the Internet cake and be a
part of it and love each other and be
great people right I gene the IG and
verse GameSpot hitman Mont to
mano-a-mano challenge brought to you by
hitman - we are now going to destroy
this cake until next time it's been a
pleasure serve you keep it alive leave
it locked out here and giant bomb
everything else and then yeah that's it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]